[Music]
no I lost my phone back hello we are
Lucas and Thomas from a Carter and this
is at Infinity at Infinity is a project
that started in 2014. during our study
years back in the days as students we
worked on solely and mere concept and
trailer we later got surprised by the
attraction it received while the idea
for this game has been stuck in our
heads for years and after several small
advances with prototypes we finally
started to commit ourselves to a
full-time production in 2019 with crazy
Ambitions and a passion for horror and
darker scene games we gathered a team of
young International passionate people in
Berlin this is my ball and don't you
you play a Young German Soldier who's
trapped between two realities within one
reality you have the opportunity to
explore a seemingly abandoned mansion in
Berlin unveil the Sinister secrets that
haunt this place while unraveling The
Echoes of its past the other reality
confronts you with the gruesome scenes
of world war one
you have to crawl for the muddy trenches
of the east of France and explore
various other places themed around the
Great Wall which you can explore on the
final game
in our game you will have to solve
intricate enigmas that challenge your
troubled mind
the mind so distorted that it is
completely losing its grip on reality
now it's up to you the player
figure out what is real and what might
be manifestations of a never-ending
nightmare
while encountering various manifested
Towers throughout the game you are bound
to uncover the tools the truth is so
disturbing that we ask you can you
handle it
we are very excited to show you more of
the game in the near future together
with naked we are hard at work to bring
the vision of Arts infinitum to life
this project is very dear to us and to
create the best possible experience for
you we have to ask you for a little bit
more patience you would never be content
to release this game that is so dear to
us in a state we deem not polished
enough this is why we decided to move
the release from April to September this
year we thank you for your understanding
and ongoing support in the meantime make
sure to wishlist the game on Steam and
follow us on social media to be updated
on the advancements of the game here you
will also be able to find more content
about Arts infinito thank you all and
see you next time
foreign